I believe that we still have
on for next, for Friday. Um,
Stephen Schwarzman,
he said he would do it.
I always worry about people who have such
important businesses because some big
deal may become an crisis.
Uh,
people like that have trouble
sometimes adhering to a schedule,
but, uh, as far as I
know, we're getting him.
So I hope that you will
all be able to come, uh,
this Friday here at the usual time.
If there's any problem with
his appearing, uh, I will, uh,
email you. Um, so as you know,
Stephen Schwarzman is a
graduate of Yale College, uh,
and he's one of the great
stories of our century. Uh,
he created a,
it's just about the biggest
private equity firm, uh,
from scratch in 1985. Uh, and, uh,
they, I guess they just went
public and they have a huge market.
Kepler comparable to one of the biggest
old line investment banks in New York,
but he just, he and Peter
Peterson just created it. Uh,
so I think it'd be very interesting to,
to hear him.
Uh, and again, uh,
you'll have a chance to question
him about what he's done. Um,
I put on the reading list, the New
Yorker article that's outright now. Well,
actually it was a, I guess it
was out of a couple of weeks ago,
but it's up on our a syllabus.
Uh,
but I think I might want to take it down
before he comes back. I ain't to turn,
I'm going to reflect on this,
uh,
because he may not be pleased
with the article. It's, it's,
it's a very hard hitting critical,
uh, article. Uh, well, you know,
he, he had to be a tough
businessman arrive at where he is.
Um, so, uh, yeah,
the New Yorker article talks about the
price of his condo or co op in New York,
which a set some record.
And so they tell the things like that.
I was just yesterday
in London, uh, and, uh,
people like to gossip
about things like that,
that the limo driver is driving me to
the airport point was pointing out the
scenes in London. He said, you
know, that building some, uh,
Arab sheik just paid a hundred million
pounds for that part of the 10,000
apartment in that
building. Uh, and the, uh,
the same sheik is
ordering a Airbus for his,
one of these big Airbus
airplanes for his personal plane,
and he's having it plated with gold leaf
that you hear the story. Did anyone,
is this true? This is what a
limo driver told me yesterday.
He said it's going to cost him 500
million pounds or something like that,
uh, to do this. Uh, but
these are, these are gossip.
They're the real substance,
uh, is what the man does,
or a woman does a for the world.
And so I gleaned a here a list
of some of the charities. Uh,
Stephen Schwarzman is a
major philanthropist, uh,
and he set up something called
the Blackstone Foundation, uh,
from the Blackstone group.
And he's a major donor or
a collaborator with, uh,
the frick collection, the
Whitney Museum, Phoenix House,
the Red Cross,
the Inner City Scholarship Fund,
New York City,
outward bound,
and the Asia Society.
So I think that's the real thing.
We should talk about not the size
of his penthouse. And so, uh,
I might try to find a more even handed
account and put that up on the website.
Um,
but incidentally it's sort
of a resemblance between
him and David Swensen in the
sem. Well, first of all, they're
both phenomenally successful,
but they both are emphasizing
alternative investments. They're,
they're not straight laced,
uh, a old fashioned there.
They're willing to take
experiments. So, uh,
so I think he should be a very
interesting, uh, anywhere. That's,
that's Friday at nine. Now, uh,
I want to talk about the stock
market today and I thought, uh,
uh, I will keep it more or
less basic because I think,
uh,
I want to emphasize basic concept,
but what I'm going to talk
about as Modigliani Miller
Modigliani Miller but are
not going to get too deep into it.
Maybe in your review sections you can
get more technical and I'm going to just
talk about it in a very
intuitive, uh, direct terms.
Uh, so, uh, what are stock? Okay.
Uh,
I think the idea of a stock must have
been invented independently at many times
in history.
Uh,
the word shares is the fundamental word.
So I suppose you are starting
a business with somebody. Uh,
it could be at any time in
history, uh, you know, Babylonia,
something this must have
happened. Okay. And so, you know,
a group of people start a business
and they say, let's divide up the, uh,
the proceeds. That's very direct, isn't
it? If we're all working together, uh,
we divide up the proceeds.
And so that means we're allocating shares.
Now, I don't know how far back it goes,
but it must be that in ancient times,
some people would say,
all right,
you're going to be doing more work
or you're contributing more to this
enterprise. We'll give you a bigger
share of the profits. Right? That's,
it's so basic. It must've happened
a million times. And that's,
that's the basic idea of,
uh, of, of the stock market.
All it is, is that we've
got much more, um, high,
high flown and much more legalized then.
So the, uh, the basic idea is that
you have to have shares in something.
Okay. Uh, uh, business. Uh,
and the idea goes back clearly to ancient
Rome that let's consider a business as
sort of a person who is on like a
slave who's owned by other people.
Uh, and in the, in law, the word person
doesn't mean what you think it means.
There's a Gnat. In Law. A
natural person is you and I, uh,
people, real flesh and
blood, blood, individual,
they're called natural persons.
But when we say person, it also,
that's more general. It also
includes corporation. Uh,
and you know, the Word Corporation comes
from the Latin Corpus, meaning body.
So it's an embodiment.
We create an entity that in,
in the eyes of the law
is like an individual.
It may be owned by other
individuals, but it is, uh,
has its own rights and responsibilities
as if it were a person. So, uh,
in ancient Rome, corporations were
called Public Connie. That's Latin.
Uh, the public Connie were, um,
were companies like we have today.
And, um, according to the research
of [inaudible] da, uh, Stanford,
uh, she thinks that, uh,
the stock market in ancient
Rome was done on the street, uh,
and the Roman forum. And she can tell you
where. So when you go to Rome, you can,
you can walk and see there what's
left of their stock market.
But it never flourished
really until, uh, uh,
relatively modern times.
MMM.
So the idea of course is
that we have a legal entity,
a corporation that issues shares that are
either given to people or purchased by
people.
Uh,
and the idea is that shares
represent contributions.
You give shares to someone who is
contributing to the enterprise. Okay.
Now, uh, you can, uh, when
you set up a corporation,
there's different kinds of relationships
that people might have to the
corporation.
One of them is as a shareholder and the
shareholder gets a share is entitled to
a share of the profits,
but there's also employees who get wages,
uh, and that's very
different. Uh, they get, uh,
they have our labor contract that
specifies how much they will get. Uh,
and then you'll have debtors. And, uh,
other people with other relationship.
But the fundamental one
is the shareholder, right?
Because the shareholder
owns the corporation.
Uh, and, uh, uh,
so,
uh,
as it's evolved in modern times,
the corporation has a
charter or the bylaws.
When you create a corporation,
you write up a contract which
specifies the rules of the corporation.
It's like a constitution
or the corporation and also
the law of the state in
which the corporation has chartered.
Also,
it puts restrictions on what
can be in the bylaws. Uh,
notably is typically required
that, uh, it's one share,
one vote, uh, and that, uh, there's, uh,
it will be also required that there'd be
an annual meeting at least once a year,
a shareholder meeting.
Uh,
and then the shareholders
can vote on relevant issues.
And one of the most important issues
then is to elect a board of directors.
And the state law probably requires that
a corporation have a board of directors,
but it's also something that can be
defined at the time that you create the
corporation in the bylaws.
But it's not something you can do,
just whatever you want. State Law, uh,
has requirements for the board
of directors. Okay. And so,
uh, uh, but anyway,
I'm just going to talk
in very basic terms.
So the usual structure is one shareholder,
one vote at the board of,
at the annual meeting.
The shareholders can come
and elect a board, uh,
and the board then a is in charge of
the company and the board hires the
president or chief executive
officer or, and other, uh,
top officers of the company, uh, and
they serve as employees of the board.
So the theory is that the shareholders
are in control because they elect the
board and the board hires the
president, uh, and its democratic.
I'm going to come back to it. It
doesn't always work out as perfectly as,
as you want, but, uh, uh, and uh,
now there's basically,
there's an important distinction
between two kinds of corporations.
There's for profit and nonprofit. Uh, I'm,
I've been describing a for
profit corporation, which
is the usual variety, uh,
nonprofit corporations. Uh, we'll
also have a board of directors,
but they will not have any shareholders
is a fundamental difference in the
charter and the way the government
reacts to them. The, the,
the nonprofit organization,
the corporation is set up
to advance some cause, uh,
and it is not owned by anyone.
Uh,
the share price you could say
is identically zero. Actually.
You can't say what the share price is
because there are zero shares and they
have a zero price.
So the value of the price per
share is zero over zero and uh,
you can't define it. So yeah, the
university is a nonprofit corporation.
The price of a share in Yale University
is undefined. It's zero over zero.
Uh, it has a board that runs it,
but the board is not liable to,
for shareholder vote. Uh, well actually
we have some voting among alumni I guess.
But, um, uh, it's not, it's
not a for profit corporation.
So I'm going to be talking
about a for profit. Now the,
the critical,
the critical thing to understand about a
corporation is that in order to value a
share in a corporation,
you absolutely have to know the
number of shares outstanding, right?
If I own a thousand shares in a
company, uh, what does that mean?
It doesn't mean anything until you
know how many shares are outstanding,
right? Because, uh,
if I own a thousand shares and then you
look it up and find out how many shares
are outstanding, there are a thousand.
You say, Hey, I own the whole company.
It's mine,
right?
If you own a thousand shares and
there are a thousand outstanding,
but what if you own a thousand shares
and there are 10 million outstanding?
Well, uh, then that means
that you own one, uh,
10,000 for the company.
They divide, right? Uh,
and so, uh, that's a very
important lesson to keep in mind.
People don't usually know how many shares
are outstanding in the company that
they invest in a,
that's because in a sense,
they're trusting two analysts.
Ultimately,
analysts are supposed to keep track of
this when they look at the price of a
company. How do we know whether the price
at which you're buying is reasonable?
Well,
they must be looking at some measure of
the value of the company and dividing by
the number of shares,
and then that gives them some
idea of what the shares worth. Uh,
but it's absolutely essential.
So the sheer is only mean something as a,
as a relation to their
total number of shares.
Their companies routinely do
what are called splits. Okay.
They may do a two for one
split, uh, and that means,
uh, if you held a thousand
shares, you get a letter saying,
congratulations,
you now own 2000 shares.
And so don't be too jubilant
because, uh, when they do a split,
they do it to every single shareholder.
Right? So you now have 2000 shares,
but now there's 20 million shares
outstanding in the company.
So the ratio is unchanged. So you
might ask, well, why do they do splits?
Well,
it's just to keep the numbers.
It's actually not a very
good reason to do split.
There's no reason not to do
splits either, uh, because it,
it's just changing the units of
measurement. But typically, uh,
in the United States,
they do split to keep the price of a
share somewhere in the 20 to $40 range.
Uh, and there's interesting
literature on why are they do that?
Maybe it's a tradition, uh, maybe
it's to keep the value of kind of, uh,
in a,
in a familiar range or a small,
they don't want them to
get too expensive because
people can't have small investors
can't afford them anymore. Who knows?
But the point is,
it's different in different countries.
So the total number of
shares is almost, uh, the,
the tendency to do splits
a is a cultural thing.
It's of no real significance.
Warren Buffet doesn't do splits
it with his Berkshire Hathaway.
And there are other companies that,
I guess Google doesn't use,
but this isn't that right? Is
that right? Are you saying no,
actually I don't remember, but
they haven't done one yet. Uh,
and so what does the price
per share, you know, so,
so this is getting a little high,
550 price it, I don't know who shoes.
These are his, I'm gonna leave their
shoes. I should have removed that,
uh,
$550 a share is kind of high because
most people will buy this part of our
tradition. Most people will buy
shares in what's called round lots.
That's a hundred shares.
So if it's, um, five,
if it's 550,
that makes 50,000,
$55,000 for one round lot.
I can't multiply and I'm
standing up. But, uh,
uh, so, uh, so they,
most companies do splits
because that might close you.
You might've been thinking investing
in Google, uh, but you could still,
you could just say,
I want to buy 10 shares or five shares
and the broker will do it for you,
but they might charge a higher commission.
Um,
so, but anyway, that's, that's
the, the, the, the lesson.
So there's a term I should
write some of my terms down,
very important term in finance.
And that's solution.
Um,
if the company increases the
number of shares through a split,
that is not delusion because it
doesn't really mean anything.
When you do a split, you're changing
the number of shares for everybody.
So it can have no effect
on the ratio for anybody.
So it's just purely appearance.
But delusion occurs when the
company changes the number
of shares asymmetrically
not changing it for everybody. So, um,
the typical example of dilution
is the board of directors, uh,
has hired a CEO for the company and
they wanted to motivate the CEO.
Uh,
they can pay the CEO or salary or
they can give shares to the CEO.
Uh, and that's quite
standard, uh, because, uh,
they feel that that makes
the CEO a shareholder.
It's like another form of compensation,
uh,
and that compensation might
have different attractiveness.
So they'll give the person a package,
both the salary and some shares,
but you see,
if they give that,
if they merely give shares to the CEO
or without increasing your shares,
then you are being diluted because it's
raising the total and it's reducing the
ratio. Uh, uh,
now if a company sells shares,
it issues new shares,
they can do that at any time. When you
start a company, you might have had like,
uh, you know, maybe when,
uh, Peter Peterson and, uh,
Stephen Schwarzman founded
the Blackstone group,
they gave each of them 500 shares.
It could be, I'm just making that up.
Uh, but obviously there's going to be more
shareholders as, as, as time comes in.
Uh, one thing that people can do
to get in is to buy shares. Uh,
uh,
if they,
if the company issues new shares
by selling them to the public,
it's not a obviously dilution,
right?
It of course it's lowering
your share of the company.
But off setting this is that the company
is taking in money from the person who
bought the shares. And so
it doesn't dilute you. Well,
you could say it dilutes your,
but it doesn't lower the price of your,
of your investment in general.
It could depending on a lot of factors.
But, um, uh, so, uh, dilution occurs,
uh,
the term specifically refers to changes
in a number of shares that affect
adversely existing shareholders.
Another common term is a
stock dividend versus license.
Talking about dividends,
sorry.
Uh, as the stock market. Okay. Let me see.
I was going to talk about stock dividend,
but I better talk about dividends
first in for profit companies,
people are investing in the
company for profit. Okay.
And how do they get the
profit? Well, the company,
the board of directors decides when,
uh,
if and when to pay dividends
to the shareholders.
And then the law of the state would say
that they must treat them all equally.
So they've made some money and now
they want to take it out and spend it.
They have to do it equally
to all shareholders.
And that's called paying a dividend.
They can do it on rare occasions or they
can do it whenever they feel like it or
they can do it regularly.
That's often done quarterly.
When I set up a company case,
Shiller Weiss Incorporated, um,
typical of young startup companies,
we didn't pay a dividend. A,
we gave shares to,
uh,
almost all of our employees as
part of their compensation. Uh,
and uh,
um,
we hope that would motivate them and
make them feel a part of the company. Uh,
but we never paid them a dividend.
I remember one time I was talking
to our CEO and he said, you know,
maybe we should pay at least one dividend
because our employees are forgetting
that they own these shares. And
so, so we paid one dividend. Uh,
and uh, I don't know how much excitement
at generated, but that's the thing. Yeah.
Does this mean that say if this stop
dividend
immediately hang up,
the price per share should go down?
Yes. Yeah. It is asking
after I firm pays a dividend,
uh,
that should lower the,
you're asking whether it should
lower the price of a share. And yes,
you are absolutely right.
Uh,
if the company pays out money that the
value of the company should have just
gone down by the amount they paid out,
but the number of shares hasn't changed.
So that means that the price of each
share should decline by the amount they
paid out, divided by the number of shares.
Uh, and there's a term for that. Uh,
they call it [inaudible]
x dividend. So, uh,
the company, uh, if you look, I
used to be, you could look on the,
we can still see this, some of
these are still listed on the stock,
New York stocking smart change page on
the day that a stock goes ex dividend,
they'll have a little x by its price.
And the reason they put that there
is so that people don't get alarmed.
So people, a lot of people watch
the price of their share every day.
Some people get neurotic about it,
right?
And then suddenly it drops by $2
a share and they say, Oh my God,
I'm worried. They call up their
broker and say what's wrong?
And then the broker has to explain, no,
no, you didn't just see the x there.
It just went x dividend. So
it doesn't mean anything. X
dividend date is the date,
not the date that you actually
received the dividend,
but it's called the ex dividend
date, which the company, uh,
decides on that day. Anyone who, uh,
was a stock holder of record gets
the dividend. And then the guy,
uh, after that, the, the, the, you
don't get that dividend. And so,
uh, that's a, that's an
important, uh, uh, and,
and this really does happen. Socks really
do drop in price on x dividend date.
Now the, uh, nine said no,
that's an interesting question that
you bring up because should I pay any
attention to dividend
dates as an investor? Uh,
the answer is generally not because
if you buy the stock before it goes ex
dividend, you get, you
have to pay a higher price,
but you get the dividend. If you,
if you wait till the next day,
you pay a lower price, but you don't
give a dividend, get the dividend.
And unless there are some tax effects,
which might matter,
the tax is always complicate things.
But unless disregarding tax effects,
it doesn't matter, uh,
which, uh, which you do.
So in fact, there's a
rule Finra, which, uh,
licenses stockbrokers tells their people
you must not sell dividends and they're
referring to a bad practice that
some unscrupulous stock brokers, uh,
occasionally do.
They'll tell someone a hurry up and buy
the stock because it's going to go x
dividend. If you buy it today, don't. If
you wait, you won't get the dividend. Uh,
uh, that's misleading because it really
doesn't matter when you buy the stock so
that you're not supposed to as
a broker sell dividends. Um,
that doesn't mean dividends don't matter.
Ultimately they're the reason why you,
uh, why you own a stock. Well,
let's gets back. This is so,
so people are accustomed to getting
dividend checks in the mail.
If you own stock,
we don't get them in the mail anymore
because you own it through some brokerage
account and you get a con,
you get on a website,
you used to get checks in the mail.
Now you go on our website and you'll
see that your dividends are credited to
your account with money is
growing in your account.
As companies pay out dividends.
I was going to talk about a stock
dividend and starting to do that.
Sometimes companies will announce that
they are paying not a cash dividend.
They're paying a stock dividend.
Uh,
and it does say we are pleased
to announce that we have,
are paying a dividend a in new shares
issued today by the company equal to 5% of
your existing share. So it's a
5% dividend. Congratulations.
Uh,
is that a good thing?
How excited we should you be to get the
letter saying your company has paid you
a stock dividend? Any idea on that? Well,
you should be absolutely unexcited
because it doesn't mean anything,
right? Because if they were giving
you extra shares and just you alone,
that would mean a great,
that would be good.
But when the whole essence of a stock
dividend is that they're paying it to
every shareholder in the same proportion,
so every 100 shares becomes 105 shared.
So you know that that has
no meaning to me, right? It,
because all that matters is the ratio.
How many shares I own divided by
the number of shares outstanding.
So if they both go up
by the same for portion,
then numerator and denominator go buy
the same amount. And so there's no,
there's no change. Uh, so
then you might ask, well,
why in the world do companies issue stock
dividends anyway? What's the point? Uh,
are they trying to confuse
or fool somebody? Uh, well,
there's different views on that.
One of them is yes,
they are trying to
confuse and for somebody,
if they don't have money
to pay the dividend,
they can always do a stock dividend. On
the other hand, some people say, well,
that would backfire, right? If,
if they're going to take stock
dividends and try to fool us,
what's going to happen? The price of a
share is going to fall on that day, right?
When you pay a stock dividend, you would
think that now there's more shares.
Everyone divides by the larger number
of shares in the value of the company.
He goes down. So it's not going
to work to pay a stock activity.
So the more enlightened view
is corporations only pay
a stock dividend when they
have some good news to announce. And so
typically they'll write a letter saying,
congratulation,
we have great news.
We have some new breakthrough
and in celebration of this,
we're going to pay everyone
a 5% stock dividend. Now, uh,
they are hoping that the price doesn't
fall because they're announcing it with
news and incense issuing this doc div.
And it's just a way to make it dramatic.
Um,
okay.
now, incidentally, in a for profit
corporation, this has to understand this,
this is a concept which
is enshrined in law.
In a for profit corporation,
the purpose of the entity is defined
as profit for the shareholders.
Now in some countries and
in some jurisdictions,
the law might not be
entirely clear on that.
They might say there are other
stakeholders, uh, but in the purest form,
and this is the form that we
have in the United States,
the company exists for the
shareholders. Uh, they're the ones,
there are other people who have contracts
with a company like the employees,
but the employees are not shareholders.
They are receiving salary
or something else. Uh,
and the important thing
for the corporation is to
live up to any promises it
made.
It has to live up to its promises.
But the purpose of the corporation
is the shareholders. Okay?
And this is a capitalist idea that
might sometimes sound wrong. Uh,
you might say, why should a company
exist for the shareholders a while?
The concept here is that
it's a good business model.
People do need money and they
go into business to make money.
And so let's make, make it clear
that's what the company is going to do.
It has to behave in an honorable way
for everyone to have to live up to its
contract. But the company generally
doesn't give to charity. It doesn't, uh,
contribute to political campaigns.
It doesn't,
it shouldn't be ideally
doing any of those things.
It should be to get money
back to the shareholders.
So if you ever serve on
a board of directors,
this is the thing that
I want you to remember.
Cause many of you will serve on
boards of directors, your you,
when you sign on to a job on the board,
okay,
you are signing on to a
solemn responsibility.
And that responsibility is to treat all
shareholders equally and fairly and make
money for them. And then you're, you're
not supposed to ever do anything that's,
that's not honest or not
living up to contract,
but your purpose has, there's only
one purpose. It's the shareholder.
When you serve on a board,
you are in a fiduciary role.
You are there to protect shareholders.
Uh, and that's the concept.
So it's for profit.
And the theory that we have in capitalist
countries is that this is a good
model. There are nonprofits
fine, but we, the, the,
a lot of the stuff that has
to be done for an economy,
it's only going to get done through
for profit corporations. Uh,
and so let's, let's make it
clear. That's make it unambiguous.
People who are on boards or our
managers of these companies,
they can give their
personal money to charities,
but they themselves are obligated
to make money. It's not,
it's not a vice.
This is the concept that is in the law.
And the reason we have it in the law is
that it works to produce prosperity and
to produce the things we need, like
clothes, medical service, home, whatever.
So that's why we do it.
And there's no shame in pursuing
profits and getting it out to your
shareholders. Now ultimately, uh,
the purpose of investing in a
share is to get the dividends.
That's the whole named purpose
of the corporation. Uh,
so,
uh,
I might add though that there are other
ways that I may have said that too
narrowly. Traditionally you
buy stocks to get dividends.
That's the reason.
Uh,
but I want to be careful about
qualifying that. Uh, first of all,
a lot of people don't seem to even grasp
that basic point that you buy stocks
for the dividends. A lot of people
think, well, I, I will buy stocks.
Well,
why do people buy stocks?
They'll buy snacks because they think
the price is going to go up and make them
a lot of money. They can sell
it at an advantage, right?
That's what most people think,
right? Do I buy stocks for dividends?
Some people don't even
know what a dividend is.
They just think of stock is something
whose price goes up, but you know,
it doesn't make sense to think that the
price of anything would go up if it's
all,
if that's all there is to it.
Why would people pay any price for stocks
if there wasn't some way to get money
out. So the ultimate thing is
the dividends that the dividends,
even though a lot of people
forget the dividends, uh,
and don't realize how important they are.
Uh, they are actually the driving force.
Now I wanted to just show you a
plot that you already saw, uh, in,
uh, your, uh, if you look down
on a spreadsheet that I had, uh,
uh, this is the stock market
for the United States.
It's the standard and poor
composite. They, uh, in 1957,
they re formulated it and they call
it the standard and poor 500. Uh,
but,
uh,
I'm using their long
theories back to 1871.
And so I can't call it the 500 are
calling it to come. How's it? Uh,
and, uh, what this is,
is the price of, uh,
a portfolio of shares in US companies.
Uh, so it's kind of like the
average price of a share,
a adjusted for splits because,
uh, you don't, you don't want to,
obviously when they do
a two for one split,
the price falls in half
and that's meaningless.
So you want to correct for splits.
So SNP corrects for splits and
follows the price of a share. Now,
unfortunately the same
companies are not around, uh,
the companies that we had in 1871,
hardly any of them are even exist anymore.
So what they do is our pricing,
a portfolio of shares and w they
keep substituting in new ones. Uh,
there's an index committee that
keeps bringing in new shares.
When new companies become important,
they try to get the 500 representative
of the most important companies in the
world and the u s and you can see
that's what the price is done.
Uh,
there's also the earnings
per share,
what our earnings per share it,
it earnings are something that accountants
have generated and they've been doing
it all the way back to 1871.
It's a venerable concept.
It's how much money did
the company make this year?
If it's annual earnings, okay. Uh,
the price of a,
of a share is a price of the ownership
of that earnings stream forever.
If I buy a share, I'm in with everyone
else who owns the company. Uh,
and I have a claim on the earning stream,
but the earning stream
is a year by year thing.
It just tells you how well they
did in that given year. Uh,
so you can see that the,
uh,
the stock market has been more
volatile than the earnings. Uh,
and the price of a share is many times
higher than the earnings per share.
So typically the, the ratio of
price to earnings has been about 15.
So that means that people will pay
up front for about 15 years earnings.
Okay. But, uh,
the company does it. Okay. Earnings
and dividends are different.
Okay. Earnings is the money that
the company made in a given year.
Okay.
How do they know what they made?
That's a complicated thing that
accountants figure out. Alright?
And accountants find it difficult
to define the earnings of a company,
but they do something and they
come up with a number. Uh,
it may surprise the company directors
how much we made or how little we made
according to the accountants. But the
dividend is something much more concrete.
This is what they actually send out.
This is cash send out to shareholders.
All right?
So earnings has kind of a theoretical
concept that accountants work on and it
can go up and down depending
on adjustments they make.
They might decide that,
you know, you, we, we, uh, uh,
we have some investment over there that
we just lost money on and we should take
a write off for that. Uh, and the,
uh, management might say, well,
what do you mean we didn't
lose any money this year?
But the accountants thought we
did. So, uh, that's earnings,
but dividends is very concrete.
It's what they send out. Um,
here is the price earnings ratio,
uh,
for the u s stock market from 1881,
to the present. Uh, and uh,
this was also on that spreadsheet
that you have on the website.
You can see that I'm saying
it about 15, 15. This is 50,
15 times earnings. It's typical, uh,
but we're in a high price earnings,
a scenario now it goes up and down
depending on your outlook for earnings and
maybe other factors.
The Red Lion as longterm interest rates,
but I want to talk more
about that right now.
But the earnings is a measure
of the value of a company.
And typically they've been valued
at something like 15 times earnings.
When the price earnings ratio gets high.
I did in 1929,
people get antsy and they thought, oh
my God, the price earnings ratio was 35.
Uh, again, this is price divided by 10
year earnings, not one year earnings.
So what I do is that we had an
extraordinarily high price earnings ratio
representing a lot of optimism in
the 20s for the stock market. Uh,
and then it corrupted him abruptly down
where that was the great depression and
we had a similar even higher price
earnings ratio of about 46 at the peak in
2000 and it corrected way down.
So the price reflects you really,
when you buy a share of a company,
you own it forever. You, you will be, uh,
you are entitled to receiving
the dividends that are
paid out of earnings, uh,
for the rest of your life. And you can
give it to your children. And you know,
maybe in 200 years from now it'll be
worth it. Probably not. But it might be,
it probably won't even
exist in 50 years, but, uh,
it will be bought by some other company
and it will still value and will still
be going up. Uh, so, uh,
that's the price of things.
Now the earnings,
you understand where I kind
of theoretical concept,
but dividend is the money
that we send out. Uh,
and so how does the company decide
on dividends? Well that's again,
up to the board to decide a or they can
set up a committee on the board that
would decide,
but ultimately that's a major decision to,
to send out dividends.
And typically,
young companies do not send out dividends.
If you've set up a company,
uh, like, uh,
you don't want to pay a dividend for
awhile because you need the money and
you're reinvesting it in the
company and people will understand,
they don't expect to get their money
out of an investment right away.
But as a company matures, then
they typically feel that, uh,
it's a time to pay a dividend.
The S and p 500 is 500 companies
who are major companies.
So these tend to be mature companies
and they tend to be in the, uh,
dividend paying stage. So
the question then is, uh,
the payout ratio, uh, pay payout ratio
is dividends over earnings.
I say div over,
he and I have the payout
ratio for the United States.
Um, that's the payout ratio. Uh,
going back to 1871, uh,
there are some spikes up,
like for example, in, um, that's
what you're here. I'm not sure what,
but yeah,
that was 1921 maybe now this year,
this is 1932 or 33 companies were paying
out 160% of their earnings as dividends
and that you might say, well, what's going
on here? It was the depression, right?
So what was actually happening is the
depression was killing these companies.
They weren't making any money.
Uh,
but they didn't want to cut their dividend
because they were afraid that if they
cut the dividend, uh, people will
be upset. So they're trying to keep,
maybe they did cut it,
they didn't cut it too much.
So that means that they were paying
out more than they were earning.
That's what typically happens in
these spike. There was a crisis. Uh,
but now there's also a trend down where
they used to pay out typically like 80%
of their earnings,
but it's been gradually going downward
and now it's down to like 40%. It's a,
that's a cultural thing I would say.
But it's that companies now
are wanting to keep the money,
and it may have to do with the fact
that people today don't seem to be as
focused on dividends.
And so that means that companies
are more able to reinvest earnings,
uh,
and a fake.
This is the dividend
price ratio back to 1871.
Uh, so back in the late 19th century, uh,
the dividend price ratio
is typically a 5%. Uh,
I think it was clearer in those days,
uh,
in terms of just general investing culture
and were behavioral and her attitude,
it was clearer that you bought
a stock to get a dividend.
Stocks were kinda different in those days.
They were more like,
railroads are steel companies. And
it was just understood. I'm, if,
if someone were at recommending
you a stock, you'd first say,
what does its dividend? And if
someone said it's 4%, you'd say, well,
that's kind of meager. You know, I, I
want a better dividend in that. Now.
People don't seem to be focused on
them. They're there. In another sense,
they're more willing to entrust the money
back to the board of directors to, uh,
to decide on m
and a,
whether to, uh, uh,
whether to pay when and whether
to pay the evidence. Uh,
now the other thing is there's another
other ways to get money out of a company
without paying a dividend.
And one of them is stock repurchase.
Uh,
well there's also a liquidation,
let you mentioned liquidation of
liquidation or sale of companies.
I'll talk about this for
a company doesn't ever
have to pay a dividend.
All I can do is keep piling into money
and accumulating it and then someone will
buy the whole company and then all of
the shareholders will be bought out at a
termination date. Uh, uh,
that's one way that I, uh, a, uh,
but often when companies are bought
out the, they don't give them cash,
they give them shares in
the acquiring company. Uh,
and so then you would be
relying on getting dividends
from the acquiring company.
Uh, so I don't emphasize this
a cash sale of a company,
but it does happen sometimes.
Um,
the other thing that a company can do
to get money out is Sherry purchase,
uh, and uh, uh, uh, stock
repurchase or share repurchase.
And it's perfectly, this sometimes
surprises people and they've delayed,
when I first think about it,
you as an individual can
call up your broker and say,
I want to buy Google
shares, right? Uh, but, uh,
uh, but, uh, Larry Page at
Google can call up a broker.
He better get the board's
permission. Uh, uh,
somebody at Google can call up your
broker and make the same statement.
We want to buy Google shares.
And so you might say, well,
how can Google by Google,
uh, why not the answer?
Why shouldn't Google by Google shares?
Then you it up. Well, let me ask you this.
What would, if if Google decided
to buy up all of it shares, okay.
Did that happen?
All right.
I'm I,
I'm the CEO of Google and
ice called the broker.
I say there is how many shares
are outstanding? Like 100
million or something? No,
it wouldn't be a hundred. Now we
know the price is $500. $500 a share.
I can figure it out more or less fit.
Well,
the answer is you. Uh, well
let me put it this way.
Let me see if this will help
you under suppose, uh, uh,
very page calls up and says,
I'd like to buy all of the Google shares.
And the broker says, all right,
I'll get them for you. Um,
and then he comes back and says,
I managed to get all about a hundred
shares and there's this one guy,
this Yale student,
a who owns a hundred shares of Google
stock and I'm having trouble getting him
to a cell. All right? So the
broker calls you up and says,
Google wants to buy back all of it.
Shit,
I'm being silly here in a few
am I can be silly like this.
What do you say to the broker then?
Okay,
so the broker calls you up and said,
you're the last guy you had the last 100
shares and Google and Google wants to
buy them and we'll give you $500 a share.
So what do you say
what?
Well, yes. You say, no, actually I
have a better thing you say. Right.
Call Larry Page and tell him he's fired.
Because I realize I own the company,
right?
If I own the last a hundred shares,
it's all mine.
I don't have to take any or do
whatever I want the last chair holder.
So a company can't buy all of it shares.
Uh,
but I can buy some of its shares and
that's another way to get money out of the
company.
MMM.
And so, uh, it's a little different
if they see, if they buy, if they pee,
suppose you own a hundred shares and
they declare a 5% cash dividends,
then you get $5.
Okay.
But what if the company buys
back 5% of its shares? Okay.
What happens then? Uh, well,
the company is still paying out
money in the same amount total.
Uh, but uh, uh,
it's coming out in a different form.
It's coming out as,
as a share repurchase is,
it's changing the number
of shares outstanding. Uh,
so the, the, the value of the
company declines by the same amount.
It has to as if they had just paid a
dividend. If they're sending out money,
the value of the company has to
go down by whatever they send out.
But with Sherri purchase,
the number of shares goes down,
and if they don't do share repurchase,
the number of shares doesn't go down.
So a sense,
it's all the same to me as a shareholder,
whether they pay
dividends or they repurchase shares. Now
I don't know how clear that all. Well,
let me just write this down. The
names. This has, this idea has a name.
Uh,
two authors,
both who won the Nobel Prize in finance,
Franco,
and I knew I was his advisee and my phd,
so I learned how to pronounce
his name, uh, motor Yanni. Uh,
because in Italian you
don't pronounce the g other,
I tend to say Modigliani just
to be understood. Uh, and, uh,
Merton Miller,
uh,
Marianna is one of the
authors of your textbook.
Uh, uh, along with full Bozi, uh,
Mariani and Miller wrote a famous
article arguing that what I just said,
I just tried to say it in a
very intuitive terms that, uh,
very nascent,
it's dividend policy
is irrelevant, although
they do put in a, uh,
a qualifier that it could matter for
tax reasons that you have to put that
qualifier on just about anything you
say in finance because the tax system is
infinitely complex and every
country has different taxes, states,
different states have different taxes.
There's nothing you can say, uh,
boldly and finance if you allow taxes.
But this just disregard taxes,
uh, when, when, when,
when Modi on this sounds like a very
strong proposition about dividend
irrelevance. And, um,
what they are saying is that of course a
lot of things that a board of directors
decides to do is not irrelevant.
It's highly relevant to the future of
the company. But real things matter.
Like if a company decides to
build that new plant in Akron,
that matters for the company.
I mean,
because if the plant
works out to be a success,
then the company will do well
and they're spending money on,
on concrete and bricks
and machinery and uh,
they could be doing
that wisely or unwisely.
And that's beyond finance to evaluate.
But when Modigliani and Miller said,
if,
if it's pure dividend policy,
then it is totally irrelevant.
It means nothing.
So companies can do whatever they please,
I don't care.
And you as a stockholder,
I don't care what they do.
And the reason Modigliani and Miller said
that is they were thinking that if the
dividend policy is going to be changed
without changing any of the activities of
the firm that is keeping it
a purely financial chain,
then it must be that they're switching
from dividends to stock repurchase or
stock repurchase to
dividends because you see,
you can keep the operations the same,
uh,
whether or not you pay a dividend,
if you saw,
if choosing not to pay a dividend
mean substituting stock repurchase for
dividend. So, uh, yeah,
I'm going to build that plant in Akron
whether I've had a dividend or not
because uh,
uh,
if I need to cut my dividend in
order to get the money to, uh, uh,
uh, to build the plant, uh,
and I would also be cutting my stock
repurchase or one way or the other,
it doesn't,
it all comes out to the same thing then.
Let me put it in the simplest way.
I think the simplest way to understand
Modigliani Miller proposition is the
following.
Imagine that we as a board decided
to pay a dividend of $5 a share.
Okay? And let's talk in the old days I
bought sending checks are, all right,
we're going to send a letter to
all our shareholders and say,
we have decided to pay
$5 dividend. Okay. Um,
and so you're about to approve this.
At the meeting we approve a letter.
The letter's going to say we're making
money, here's your dividend check.
And then someone says, hey,
why don't we just change it?
Why don't we say same $5 check is include,
but in the letter,
let's say something different.
Let's say this is a repurchase of,
uh,
of some of your shares at market
price saying the same check.
Right? Uh, and so what's
the difference? Uh, well,
I'll ask you what difference does it make?
Suppose you get a letter from your
company saying, congratulations,
here's a $5 dividend and here's
a check for $5. If you're,
if you own one share or the company says,
congratulations,
we're repurchasing, uh, 2%
of your shares, uh, and uh,
and here's a check for $5 to pay you
for those shares. Okay? And by the way,
we're doing that with all shares,
but if you think about it,
it doesn't make any difference to me,
right?
It doesn't matter what that letter says.
I can crumple it up and throw it in the
wastebasket. I don't, I want the $5 check.
If they're paying me by sending
money and calling it a dividend,
it's the same as if they say they're
repurchasing my shares because it's
repurchasing my shares. If they do it
for everybody, it doesn't mean anything,
right? I'm getting,
uh, we're all lowering.
All of our shares are going
down by the same amount.
So that's the basic insight and
a Modigliani and Miller that um,
that share repurchases and dividends
are really interchangeable.
It's just all a conceptual
difference. So, uh,
this kind of took people by surprise.
It's kind of odd. It should be obvious.
I'm making it so simple.
I can write some mathematics to try and,
but I think it's so simple
and obvious that uh, uh,
you just have to keep remembering
that all that matters for a company,
for you as a,
your interest in a company depends on
your share is divided by the total number
of shares and a stock repurchase.
If they repurchase,
everybody shares the same proportion.
It doesn't affect that ratio.
So you don't care what the letter says,
whether it says a dividend
or stock repurchase. Okay.
So why would a company want
to do one or the other? Well,
what are yawn and Miller
are leaving the room.
They say it doesn't matter if you asked
them why a dividend payout policy has
changed. Uh, there's a
famous, uh, Miller quote,
he calls a neutral mutation.
Um,
a and as a reference to evolutionary
biology that sometimes mutations are
neither advantageous nor
deleterious. And so, uh, the,
the genome starts piling on mutations that
mean nothing. Uh, that's how they date,
uh,
ranches of the genome by looking
at the number of neutral mutation.
And he said all this, this
thing that I have up here, well,
the previous slide showing
the dividend earnings ratio,
it's just cultural. It means
nothing, uh, because, uh,
uh, to some extent what was not shown
in that diagram is the stock repurchase.
Uh,
I wanted then finally to talk about Modi,
Yani Miller and debt. Now, I didn't
talk too much about debt yet,
but um, Oh, before I tell you,
I just want to say one more thing about
Modigliani Miller dividend irrelevance
of dividends.
There is a possible correction
to be made due to taxes when,
what are Yani and Miller road?
There was a differential tax rate
between dividends and capital gains.
And so, uh, it was muddy
Yanyah Miller said back then,
this is like 30 or 40 years ago that
companies should really not pay dividends
because dividends were then taxed
at a higher rate than capital gains.
And so you don't want
to give your employees,
your shareholders taxes.
You should in your fiduciary duties as
a board member be trying to help them
lower their taxes.
It doesn't say that on the state law,
but that would be an inferred
as the, uh, as the duty.
So you would avoid paying
dividends, uh, and uh,
and therefore switch to share
repurchase as your method. This,
it took decades for Modigliani
Miller to kind of sink in. But, uh,
as you can see it, part of the reason
why the dividend earnings ratio,
especially in more recent years since
1990 has been declining as corporations
were trying to somewhat ease the tax
burden on their shareholders by doing
repurchase instead of dividends.
However,
that all changed in 2003 with the jobs
and growth tax reconciliation act of
2003,
which cut the rate of
taxation of dividends to 15%.
The same rate that
capital gains are taxed.
So there is now no preference
and whether it could be,
there's a lot of
complexities in the tax law,
but basically a dividend policy really
is irrelevant now because if we,
if, if there's no tax advantage to one
over the other, it is completely neutral.
The, um, the other thing that
I wanted to say about, um,
Modigliani and Miller is
about corporate debt. Uh,
and um, so, uh,
I have to bring one of these.
So the,
I talked about a company as
having only shares outstanding,
but they also have debt outstanding.
Okay.
So a company can borrow money.
Uh,
if a company borrows a lot of money,
it's called, it's be called leveraged,
uh,
and it's leverage is measured
by the debt equity ratio.
Now d here,
r stands for debt.
A minute ago I was using Dev
Div to stay on for dividends.
They've all started with the letter d.
Okay.
About very different concepts.
The debt of a company is the amount of
money it goes either to banks or to bond
holders or to note holders
or commercial paper holders.
These are our fixed incomes.
In other words,
they are not shares in the company.
When a company becomes leveraged,
uh, it, uh,
it then becomes riskier.
The company becomes riskier because,
uh,
the earnings they have available,
after paying interest on the debt or
repayment of principal of the debt is what
they have available for dividends.
And if that becomes high
relative to their revenue stream,
then they, the company is,
is in a riskier situation.
Uh, so there's another
Meridiani Miller theorem
about debt,
uh,
which is about
debt irrelevance as well. That's,
uh, that sounds funny, but
uh, in a sense that is,
we have to define the sense
in which it's irrelevant. Uh,
it certainly isn't irrelevant
to the price of a share.
The more money I company borrows a,
the more risky the share
becomes. Uh, and so,
uh, it's just like a few,
if you buy a house, uh,
and you buy,
a lot of people are very leveraged now.
They might put a only 10% down on a house.
So you buy a house for $300,000,
and you put $30,000 down.
Okay.
That's a sort of investment of $30,000.
But it's highly risky because you are
very leveraged when you only put 10% down,
uh, because, because the home price falls
by only 10% that could eat. In fact,
that's what's been happening lately.
You're a $30,000 down payment
is completely wiped out, right?
Cause you were leveraged.
You bought the house for 300,000.
You sell it for 270,000. Uh,
that's exactly what you owe.
So you have nothing left,
right? So leverage brings risk.
So boards of directors have long
agonize over how much to borrow.
Uh, and uh, different companies
seem to have different cultures.
So for example,
Microsoft has
avoided borrowing any
money. Uh, and they, uh,
they uh,
don't believe in debt has,
so they are not leveraged.
Uh,
but other companies get heavily indebted
and then they can go through big
problems. Uh, so, uh, it's a,
it's a very common item of discussion
at board meetings about how much should
our company bow.
All right?
And so they seek advice
from financial experts, uh,
so they call it muddy Yani
and Miller and ask, uh,
how much should we borrow? What
do finance theorists say? Uh,
and in the extreme case
where we disregard taxes and,
uh,
we have to disregard some other problems,
we get the same answer. A Modigliani and
Miller says, we don't care what you do,
do whatever you want, it
doesn't matter. Uh, and so, uh,
this,
this is what I want you to think about
on the problems and maybe thinking about
the answer to the questions on the
problem set. Number four will, uh,
help you to think this through.
But the simplest way to see woody,
Yani Miller debt irrelevance
is the following.
What is a company?
If you wanted to buy a company,
you could buy only the stock,
the shares or equity incident.
Did I ever equity equal shares?
All right, uh, our stock.
So, uh, when I talk
about debt equity ratio,
I'm talking about the ratio of the value
of the company's debt to the value of
all of its stock.
Okay?
Um, so, um,
if you wanted to buy a company up
and own it yourself completely,
you could conceive of buy all
the shares in the company, right?
There's a 10 million shares outstanding.
I'm going to buy 10 million shares.
But in a sense,
I don't really own the whole company
yet because the company owes money.
So what if I wanted to buy the whole
kitten caboodle, the whole operation?
I should be buying all the equity
and all the debt as well. Right?
So if the company issued by, if I really
want to own it and I have no, you know,
I really wanted to be the tycoon who this
is my baby and nobody else can get in
my backyard. Uh, I can do whatever I want.
You'd have to buy all the equity
and all the debt. Right? And, uh,
otherwise if you don't buy all the debt,
you still have problem because those
debtors can go after you because they are,
they're not shareholders, but they have
rights. And they could come in and say,
we don't like what you're doing.
We're going to sue you because we think
that you are doing something contrary to
our interest as debtors. So if you're
really worried about the company,
you buy up all its equity,
all of its shares and all of its debt.
So the basic insight about, uh, uh,
what are the Yani and Miller
debt irrelevance is that, uh,
in the absence of taxes or
any other special thing there,
the real value of the company is going
to be unaffected by whether they financed
by debt or buy equity.
Because the real value of a company is
determined by the cash flow that they
generate by the business they're doing.
And so they,
they are selling widgets or
whatever and making money.
The value of the company is the
present value of that cashflow.
And if you want to buy the company,
you have to buy up all the debt.
And all of the equity.
All right.
So from the standpoint of a
buyer of the whole company,
what do I care how the ownership of the
company is divided up between debt and
equity? I have to buy
them all anyway. So, uh,
I don't care whether three quarters of
my money goes to deck with debt or one
quarter of the money goes to debt.
I just want to know the bottom line.
How much do I have to pay
for the whole company?
So the debt irrelevance theory says,
yeah,
uh,
it matters for the price
of a share what a company,
uh, issues, uh, how much
it debt it takes on.
But it doesn't matter for the
value of the company. Uh, and so,
uh, there's almost an
arithmetic relationship theory
that they put forth and that
kind of go see their numbers, but, um,
but the value of the company as a
whole is really determined by something
outside of finance. So, um,
uh,
there again,
we have to qualify the debt irrelevant
for tech irrelevance for characters.
Um, and uh, and so,
uh, companies, um, uh, might, uh,
um, they might be concerned with, uh,
the fact that debt is tax deductible for
corporations on their corporate profits
tax. Uh, uh, but, uh,
dividends are not. So, uh,
according to [inaudible] and Miller,
if you add taxes to their
debt irrelevance proposition,
it means that companies will want to
bow a lot and that the real advice they
would be giving to Bill Gates is,
uh, what's the matter with you?
Why aren't you borrowing money?
It's tax deductible. Uh, whereas,
uh, uh, dividends are not.
And so that would mean that companies
should try to push their debt equity ratio
up as high as possible,
um,
given that, um, uh, that
theory on the other hand,
um, if they do so, they
may be cording bankruptcy.
If a company gets to leveraged,
then there's too high a probability
that the company will fail.
And, uh, and there's costs to bankruptcy.
So the other qualification
is bankruptcy costs.
So a company,
uh,
according to Modigliani and Miller has
to weigh their tax considerations against
their bankruptcy costs and get an optimal,
uh,
debt equity ratio out of that. So it, uh,
it is some insights that Meridiani and
Miller are offering the corporations that
I think they often don't see that the
real issue in the dividend and the
dividend and the debt policies are
really taxes, uh, and nothing else.
Uh, the last thing I just wanted to
say, uh, Amanda mentioned the, um,
uh, the, uh, theory of, uh,
of a
dividend payout given by John Lintner,
uh,
and it's called the
Lindner model of dividends.
So I'm saying that,
uh,
unless tax considerations intervene,
dividend policy is really
irrelevant for a firm.
Uh, so what, and so, um,
maybe Merton Miller is right,
these things are neutral mutations
and changes in dividend policy are
meaningless, but how do they
actually do it? Uh, how do,
how do boards and their committees
decide how much to pay out in dividends?
So John Linton, her was a professor
at the Harvard Business School,
who decades ago did a survey of people
who decide on dividends and asked them
what goes on in your mind and what
do you think about when you decide on
dividends?
Uh,
and he had a long discussion of they
said millions of different things.
It's very hard. People who
decide on dividends, uh,
are facing a complicated issue.
But one thing that Merton Miller distilled
from him was that people on boards
who decide on dividend payout are
very focused on the price of a share.
And they're worried about
investor reaction. Uh,
boards always want to keep their price
of a share up because if it starts to
decline, the company could become a
takeover target. It's viewed as a failure,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
So they talked a lot to him
about investor psychology.
And so in a sense that I'm
terminating this lecture with a,
another triumph for behavioral economics.
When we think about the theory of dividend
or that we ended up with irrelevance,
it doesn't mean anything.
But the companies boards talk about it
incessantly and it seems to matter a lot
to them. And if you ask them
why it matters, they say,
well, it's pretty obvious.
It's all their investors psychology
that we have to deal with.
And they say things like this.
If we said if we pay a dividend,
then they're going to start expecting
that. And if we don't pay a dividend once,
then they're going to say,
what's wrong?
As long as we never
start paying a dividend,
then we're just a young company
and nobody asked any question. Uh,
then we start paying a dividend and
then, uh, if we ever have to cut it,
we're in big trouble in the newspaper.
Reporters will start calling,
why did you cut the dividend?
And he said,
you didn't call us up when we
weren't paying any dividends.
And now we're still paying more than
we used to. Why, why all this alarm?
And so they said one of the lessons,
they were told to never cut a dividend
unless you do it as you could do a
onetime only dividend's safe.
We're just doing this once
and don't expect it again.
But if you start paying regular dividends,
then you'd better keep doing them where
people are going to conclude something
is really wrong.
So they told him that if earnings go up,
we try to keep a target payout ratio,
but if earning suddenly shoot out,
we're not going to increase our dividends
right away because that would set too
high an expectation. We don't want to have
to cut it. So if earnings go up a lot,
we will raise our dividends
but only part of the way up.
And so the um, the model
that I'm, well, I better
get it right. The letting her
model, uh, says that, um, uh,
there's a target payout ratio
that's the Greek planner tau and
that's the target payout ratio.
That ratio may have been
higher in the 19th century.
It's gradually trending down,
but it's a slowly moving thing.
So they want to pay out something like
40% of their earnings as dividends and
plow the rest back into
investing inside the company.
And then there's another parameter raw,
which is the adjustment.
Uh, so, uh,
and roe was between zero and one.
It's how far,
how fast they adjust to the target.
And so the Lenten,
her model then says the
change in dividends,
dividend at time t minus dividend at
time t minus one a is equal to roe times
earnings
at time t minus dividend t minus one.
Okay.
So that means that if your
row is some positive number,
like a half, uh, and so if
earnings is above dividends,
you increase your dividends but only buy
half as much as we'd bring it up to the
target if roe is a half. Uh,
and so that means there's,
and then there's a gradual adjustment
of earnings of dividends to earning.
So for example, I don't have
any more space to write if, uh,
if, uh, this is time and this is earnings.
If your earnings were say flat
and suddenly increased like that,
they wouldn't believe
this increase at first.
So the board would decide to adjust,
only say halfway up.
Now I'm flooding dividends. The dividends
were down here at half the earnings,
and then you would gradually adjust
them up to half earnings. Again,
that's because they don't want to ever
be caught cutting their dividends. Uh,
and also if the earnings drop,
they don't want to suddenly do a
crash cutting their dividends either.
So they're always sluggishly adjusting
towards the target payout rate, uh,
and, uh, letting her show
that this simple model, the d,
The Lintner model explains,
uh,
the behavior of companies
pretty well. Okay. So, uh,
next session is Friday and
with Stephen Schwarzman,
uh,
and I'll see you then.